[Epic voice] Last time on Dragonball Z...
Rock, Paper, Scissors...
And now, the epic conclusion!
SHOOT! YESSSS!
*Slow motion* YESSSS!
*Laughter*
It's about damn time, ya maroon!
Boink!
Five
Mark: Root beer! Yeeaah! *Laughing*
Tyler: YOU GOT THE ROOTBEER
Mark: YEAAAAAAAAH
Tyler: NOOOOOOO!
-heh-heh-heh-heh-heh-he-hey
Awww, the first sodey pop!
Tyler: We wanted to put the sodey pop in that one...
Mark: I get to use a ferk! (fork)
Oooh, geez.. *Metal ringing*
Calm down there, ferk! *Crazy laughing*
That ferk is PISSED!
*More laughing* Calm down there, ferk.
Oh, it's so foamy!
I can't tell where the... OOOOH!
*Laughing* I hope there's liquid in there 'cause I poured like two drops!
*Both laughing*
STOP!
Awww. W-when I win, amazing things happen!
This is incredible!
This is totally gonna mess up the audio..
shh-I don't care, man, that's cool!
Wait, it's speaking to us in a morse code..
What's it say?
It's saying...
...you're gay.
*uncontrollable laughter*
*More uncontrollable laughter*
*Even more uncontrollable laughter*
I love dry ice. Why don't I get more dry ice? This is so cool.
We have two more.
Oh yeah! *giggling*
We've got extra dry ice but it's not this big, nice, solid block.
I think you could probably take a bite..  Yeah, I think mine's good to go
That looks like a popsicle! That's a pretty-looking popsicle.
Ew I forgot this wasn't cleaned out.. *Laughing*
Well, alright, it's gonna have some flavours to it.
*Tyler tasting the popsicle* Actually, I didn't taste any of that
It tastes fruity!
Oh God, that bag looks horrible..
We're not gonna show you the bag--
we've been talking about the bag the whole time.
--We're not gonna show the bag until...
the end of the challenge.
AND IT'S BAD. It's real bad.
Rock, paper, scissors, shoot!
Rock, paper, scissors, shoot! X2
Rock, paper, scissors, shoot! X3
*Laughing*
I knew you were gonna do something like that, I saw the gleam in your eyes!
Right when I hit scissors you were like YESSSS! I'm gonna ROCK this!
Why did you go scissors? *Laugh* You were just doing-
'Cause I was thinking the gleam was "You're gonna trick me", and I was gonna do rock again and you're gonna do paper!
Yeah, whatever! *Laugh*
I THOUGHT TOO MUCH!
Yeah you did!
Alright, let me generate that.
Oh my God...
What?
Finger..
One.
*Same time* NOOOO! YEAHHHH!
*More insane giggling* NOOOO!
YES!
Oh, there's only one gross one left!
I'm doing the popsicle on this side.
Okay.
It might be good; honey!
Honey MUSTARD.
Which, I like honey mustard.
Yogurt dressing.
I dunno, I've had yogurt dressing before, but not this..
*BURP*
*Tyler laughing* [Mark.exe has encountered a problem]
Tyler:Oh, Ugh! Mumble Mark:Let me get that for ya..
That doesn't smell very good..
Smells like honey mustard but it smells also wrong..
Yeah..
Awww, that's, that's, that's goopy..
Gimme a nice...
Oh yeah...
No, no you can stop now.
I had to excavate mine out; the fork was actually getting embedded in here,
And the fork is like.. frozen solid
so it might be super brittle.
*Tyler mumbles, Mark in a high voice*
MIne's- Mine's pretty there.
I got a...
You got a nubbin'.
*Laugh*
I got a boober on mine, just like you got a boober on yours!
Cheers!
*Laughing*
It...
It might be bad.
*Choking Sounds*
Nah, It's delicious!
*Through giggling* I'm havin' a great time.
*Laugh*
*Markigiggles*
Mmm mm *Head shaking*
Uh oh..
Mmm mm *More head shaking*
Uh oh!
*Mouth Giggles*
If you vomit in the bag, we have to eat the vomit too.
We have to make a vomit popsicle!
That's pretty good.
The only problem is-
Bag!
*Faint mumble* Take it..
Okay! *Whisper*
RUN!
You wanna tasty replacement?
*whimpering* Yes please.
I'll try this.
*Mark's taste-buds are screaming*
I told you it was bad!
That's the worst one...
*Giggling*
...so far.
*Silent sounds of regret*
You okay?
I can't believe you tasted it after I gagged!
*Gulp* (Feel bad for the poor Mark)
*giggling*
Gah...
I made it!
I didn't go- I didn't go to the bathroom,
I just went off camera and drank some water.
That is hhhorrifyingly bad!
That's horrifically bad!
Worst- Worst one by far.
That's by far.
And we got one more that might be worse!
Kale parmesan!
Oh, but this is good though!
Yeah, that was really good!
*Hands slapping palms*
Dammit!
You did it again!
I-
I was just gonna be rock!
I can't believe you did it again!
Oh I love that.
Ah- you've got a 50-50 shot of getting something really delicious.
*Simultaneously* YEAAAAAH!
DUUUUUDE!
You did it!
The scissors really got you through that!
Aw, congratulations dude.
You're gonna trick me this next time.
How am I gonna trick you?
You're not gonna do rock.
I'm gonna do rock.
I swear
on my mother.
[Mark.exe has froze and needs to reboot]
I'm gonna do rock.
Did you shake this?
No?
Why do you think I'm gonna trick you?
*Sizzling noises*
So, again to save time because uh-
We're both running out of camera battery and camera space
And also the dry ice is fading, and we got just a little bit of this channel left
I'm gonna get this one started.
I'm gonna make a small popsicle of the kale parmesan
It's number 2.
It's number 2. On the roster.
And if one of these goes, we'll keep it on number 2
so it doesn't change.
Alright?
So this is gonna just be ready because it got oil in it and I don't know if it's gonna freeze
so we just need to see
if it will.
*Surprised oh*
*Disturbed oh*
Oh no.
Alright. So that one's gonna be there.
Ooh this is a beautiful-
*In a Scottish accent* That's a beautiful popsicle
I'm sorry, I go Scottish when I'm nervous.
Definitely taste like coke.
You know like frozen coke from Burger King?
Yeah, like coke ICEE™?
Yeah, tastes just like that.
Oh, wow, that tastes just like coke!
This is ready to go,
So if anyone gets this it's immediate.
*Rock paper scissors*
YEAAAH!
I told you I was gonna do it!
I didn't trust you! *laughs*
*laughing* I told you I was gonna do it,
I told- okay.
1 out of 3.
Alright, boom.
Aaaah alright, better than 2.
Woo it's better than two.
Oh shit- oh God.
It's going everywhere.
Why are you- you put it- you mixed it.
I did not.
"I did naaaght".
Alright this is ready.
We're trying-
We're trying to do math and we're not good at that.
So it wasn't working out too well.
So I don't imagine this is going to be too bad.
It's dripping carrot
yay
The fact that it's frozen makes it solid again
*swallows*
I tastes like a carrot
*laugh*
Mark: Like literally seems like I'm just biting into a carrot
Tyler: And look, it looks kinda like a carrot before you bit into it
This is literally a carrot that's been turned back into a carrot
*laugh*
It's- It's good!
It tastes like a carrot
*With carrot in his mouth* It tastes like a carrot
It's a carrot
It's just a frickin' carrot
It tasted kinda like a baby carrot.
Yeah, not bad.
Through a mathematical process, that uh,
there's no way that Tyler can win.
And by points, because there's only 13 challenges, uh,
and the last bag is a, 14.
So it'd be unfair to say that the loser has to eat it 'cause he'd already have to eat it.
I've already gotten more than him, so we'll do a final test.
And see- we'll do a best 2 out of 3.
Okay. That's stupid
Let's not do 2 out of 3
*Laugh* Oh, that's stupid!
Rock, paper, scissors, shoot
Yeah!
*laughter*
Man, it was like...
This is gonna be either really good, or really bad!
*more laughter*
My secret straaaategy has been foiiiled...
Two choices.
Yep.
*screaming and laughter*
*Mark sighs*
So this is really frozen.
It's been freezing for quite a while- I'm gonna go ahead and- yeah, go ahead.
-and pour the Mountain Dew
'Cause we know what it's gonna be
God, why did I reveal my strategy?
This cannot be good
*crunching noises*
Oh!
Ah!
[Mark.exe has froze]
*Loud gulp*
*Tyler laughing* Is it as bad as the mustard?
*More laughter* Oh my god
*Mark punches his chest* Oh my god! *Tyler laughing*
This is bad!
*More laughing* *can is knocked*
*Mark gagging & coughing*
Ugh.
Oh my god..
*heavy sigh*
Here, have some Mountain Dew
No, I gotta earn it
Oh my god, that was so bad!
Ordinarily I'd be like "Try it!" - Don't try this!
You will puke! *laughter*
And it even got some carrot splashed on there from the last one, but that didn't cut the flavor at all
Oh my god, that's terrible!
Okay, so we gotta fight for the rights of the Mountain Dew .
*both laughing*
God, that was awful!
That was WAY worse than the honey mustard.
And it's hard to say "WAY worse"- it was WAY worse.
Like, WAY worse.
*deep sigh*
This is gone.
Alright.
It was on your side.
Just for the sweet taste of delicious Mountain Dew *Both laugh*
Is there a way to purposely lose?
*Heavy sigh*
*hands clap together*
AHHH!! No! I want it so badly!
You did it.
No.
Oh.
[Mark.exe has encountered a problem and needs to reboot]
You get it.
Oh.
But it's- the loser gets it, generally
[Mark.exe is rebooting]
Oh!
*Both burst into laughter*
Yay! I get it, yes!
*Uncontrollable laughter*
Yay!
*More uncontrollable laughter*
I'm an idiot.
I was like "Are you switching the rules on me for this one?"
I'm an idiot- No, I was just dumb
That's okay
Ah, what a lovely, lovely thing
It tastes like flat Mountain Dew, is the thing
All the carbonation gets blown away in the cold
I like that- Okay, so now comes the big bag reveal
Uh, we've been- We've been, creating this uh
Eugh.
*Disgusted grunts*
Can we not?
I'm going- How are there chunks in here?
Because you have the cream with the oils and the-
That doesn't- How are there chunks?!
I can't even stomach looking at it let alone smelling it.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna make a popsicle outta this.
Ohhhhh, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho. Oh, the chunks!
Oh god!
Oh, my god!
*Disgusted noises*
Blegh!
Oh, geez.
Oh, close that demon portal.
I can't even look at it
Oh my god, why is it so chunky?
Tyler: Stop talking about it, you're gonna make me puke! Mark: It's so chunky!
It's so chunky, dude!
*Tyler gags*
*Mark mocks Tyler's gagging*
Shut up, I'm actually gagging!
*More mock gags*
Why are you out of breath?
You don't understand how nervous I am!
*Both laugh*
*Hands clap together*
*Screaming & laughter*
This is your scissors?!
I don't know! I was like, halfway between choosing paper or scissors
I won, though!
*Laughing* That's not fair!
You said 2 out of 3!
You said- You said 2 out of 3!
*Slow motion* "We'll do a best 2 out of 3? I'm stupid"
You said it, you said it! *Tyler grunts*
This is how you twist things so you win!
You said it!
*Hands clapping together* *Tinnitus plays*
*Both giggle*
*Hands clapping together*
*Screaming & laughing*
*Mark laughs*
Alright, okay, alright
*heavy breathing*
*Hands clap*
*Screaming that turns into laughter*
You have to eat it! You have to!
*More laughter*
This is gonna be so bad
*Mark uncontrollably laughing*
I'll- I'll eat it with you- I'll eat it with you!
Oh, geez
I'll eat it just for that happening!
*incoherent laugh-talking*
What, it's my strategy!
It's to confuse you, to make you think I'm doing paper
Bunny ears!
*Laughing* Shut up!
Precautionary measures, gimme that!
I, uh, I got a bowl for ya
I'm gonna try not to
I mean, it's- It can't be THAT bad
Are you looking at it?!
Yeah, uh *burp* so?
*Tyler laughs*
He's too good at Rock, Paper, Scissors
How am I good at Rock, Paper, Scissors?!
You just win all the time! *laughter*
You will see, in other videos!
Eugh. Flip- just flip it over
Okay, just to get a nice coating on the other side
Hey, it doesn't look so bad anymore!
I like the dick on it.
*Laughing*
We're men of our word...
And he lost.
*Laughing*
Even though he shouldn't have lost.
I'm a man of my word.
Okay...
This is gonna be so bad.
Just a little bit.
Doesn't have to be a big one.
Oh, geez.
I'm sorry- I'm sorry! Oh, I'm sorry!
Oh, no!
Be okay- *gags* Oh, god no, I'm sorry
Alright...
It's mostly Siracha, but there was the lemon-lime in that bite
Oh, you took a bigger bite, that was a mistake
*Quiet laughing*
I'll go throw it away now
Do you need?- I'm bringing this over in case
*Grunting*
It's just going in the bag
*Mark coughs and grunts*
It went with it's friends
*Gagging*
Okay, we did it!
I'm making a root beer one
It's still in my mouth
It's still in my mouth!
Oh that was bad. We didn't even get to the kale chunks
If we would've gotten to the kale chunks, that would've been so bad
Thank goodness this wasn't the "Eat the whole popsicle" challenge, because my goodness...
Okay, so anyway- get that- I'm trying to talk, here!
Alright, so that is the Dry Ice Popsicle Challenge
It was a lot of fun. Took a while, but I mean, that was the most fun I've had shooting a video in a long time!
Like, legitimately, that was really fun!
So, uh, we hope you enjoyed it
Thanks Tyler, any final words from you?
Uh, no, uhm, other than- If you guys decide to make popsicles with dry ice at home, uh, we'd certainly like to see it
And uh - yeah - tell us in the comments below, what your favourite parts were
Yeah, and uh, you know, choose tasty ingredients for your popsicles, because, my god
This- this bag of ethereal horrors that you can still see the blots from- there's more chunks!
Is that fruit?!
Dude, it's fruit!
That's from the original popsicle! I forgot they got mixed in!
Ohhh!
Nice!!
There's real fruit in there!
Oh, it's not so bad
So anyway, thank you everybody so much for watching
If you wanna see more challenges like this, let us know in the comments below
Thanks again, and as always, we'll see you in the next video
Buh-bye!
Bye!
Eugh